welcome to building web apps with the
myrn stack using MongoDB Atlas and
Google cloud platform we are going to be
learning the myrn stack by creating an
exercise tracker app my name is beau
Carnes and I am a teacher and developer
with free cokie org
we will be first starting with an
introduction to the myrn stack then
we'll be going over some database
concepts then we will talk about how to
get started with MongoDB Atlas which is
the database we'll be using for the our
myrn stack app then we'll be getting
into our code and I will be actually
creating the backend of the exercise
tracker app and showing you how I do it
after that we will have an introduction
to react and then start creating the
front end of the exercise tracker app
with react and finally we'll connect the
front end to the back end so what is the
myrn stack well it consists of the
following technologies we have MongoDB
Express react and nodejs that's what
myrn stands for so nodejs is the
JavaScript runtime environment that
allows you to exercise JavaScript code
outside of a browser such as on a server
and express is a web application
framework for nodejs it allows us to
easily create a web server and then
MongoDB is the document based open
source database so in our app will be
storing our data in MongoDB and then
finally the front-end is react which is
a JavaScript front-end library for
building user interfaces and then
finally at the bottom there we will be
using mongoose which is a simple schema
based solution to model application data
basically it makes it easier to use
MongoDB
in nodejs so let's review some database
concepts we're gonna just review some
terminology so what a lot of people are
used to are tabular or relational
databases so we think of things like
databases tables rows and stuff like
that so MongoDB has similar concepts
that use different terms so I just want
to come make everyone aware of those
terms so instead of table we have
collections instead of rows we have
documents we can do join operations with
the lookup operator instead of foreign
keys we utilize references and just as a
point of clarification a lot of people
talk about MongoDB as a non relational
database but really all data is
relational so sometimes I use the term
tabular to describe the legacy databases
that use tables MongoDB is very
well-suited for handling data with a
wide variety of relationships we're not
going to cover all of these concepts in
the app today but I just wanted you to
be aware of some of the differences so
let's look at the document model this is
an example of what a MongoDB document
looks like it looks a lot like JSON we
can see a variety of relationships and
address a title and MongoDB stores data
on disk in the beasts on format which
stands for binary JSON this provides a
wide variety of support for data types
like strings and integers the document
model also allows for nesting documents
inside each other these sub documents
are one of the great things about the
document model so it allows us to apply
the concept of data that's accessed
together is stored together in an
application we also have the ability to
store information inside arrays which is
another powerful feature of the
model and as I mentioned these documents
are JSON structured objects which is how
most developers think of things so a
person is an objects that has various
attributes like a job title address and
stuff like that so this allows modern
development practices to use the
document model in a very intuitive way
without having to break the data apart
to put into tables and normalize things
so we will be using MongoDB Atlas which
is a really fast and easy way to get
started with MongoDB so some people
would just run up MongoDB locally on
their local computer for testing but
MongoDB analyst actually makes things a
lot easier even if you're just doing a
local project so the first step for
getting started with MongoDB Atlas is to
sign in so if you go to the web page
you'll just get this getting started
screen and once you've logged into
MongoDB ant lists we need to set up a
place to store the data we need a
cluster so this is the screen that
you'll see when you first get logged in
and to start building the cluster you're
gonna click the new project button
that's the button right here and then
after you click that you'll be able to
build a cluster the big green button in
the middle here allows us to create and
configure a cluster so once you click
that it will bring you to this screen
where you can create a new cluster so
here you can see that in MongoDB Atlas
there's a bunch of providers will be
using Google cloud platform and then you
can choose the region we're gonna be
using the free tier today which is gonna
be great for our app and this one you
get getting started and learning how to
use things I recommend starting with the
free tier and then once you get things
going you can always switch to another
tier later so you just gotta click a
region associated with the free tier
and then so the free tier is just the mo
sandbox it gives a server side a server
size of 512 megabytes which is typically
plenty to get started with and then one
thing to notice is that the bottom is
always going to show you how much things
cost so in this case it's free then you
can click create cluster and then the
provisioning will start so you can see
it says it's going to take seven to ten
minutes to provision and it's often
quicker than that but you know it's just
gonna take some time to set things up so
once it's created we're ready to get a
couple of security things configured and
finally get a connection string so once
it's configured you'll be on this screen
where you can set up the security and
just so you know I'm doing this all in a
slideshow right now but in a in a little
bit will actually be on the actual
website so you can see where the all
this is on the actual website but from a
security standpoint we need to set up IP
whitelist addresses and a database user
so for this project since it's just
going to be hosted on locally we can add
your current IP address for the
whitelist IP address and then you can
create any username and password for the
MongoDB user so now we can get our
connection information there are a few
different ways that we provide
information to connect to MongoDB Atlas
through the MongoDB shell which is a
command line interface with the
application connection string which is
what we'll be using today and through
MongoDB compass which is a GUI tool for
interacting with data stored in MongoDB
so then after you click the connect your
application you'll be taken to the
screen on the right here and we're
provided information on getting a
connection
string and then some connection examples
for different languages but we'll just
need the connection string and normally
you would click copy here but this is
just a slideshow so I can't do that but
we will be going to this exact screen
and copying the connection string to use
in our app okay we're just about to
write some code but let's just quickly
review the collections in our database
our application is going to contain
exercise exercises and users and every
exercise has one user once you see how
simple this is you'll realize that we
could have probably just had one
collection but just for the sake of
example to see how it would work we're
gonna have the exercises and users
collection so now we would really we'll
get into the code so I have Visual
Studio code up here and the first thing
we're gonna do is verify node is
installed so I'll just do node - V and I
do have it installed if you don't you're
gonna have to make sure you install it
but I'll leave that up to you to figure
out how to do that so next we'll create
the initial react project by using
create react app and if we use the MPX
command then we can run create react app
without installing it first
so although MPX create react app and
then I'm just going to be calling it
burn exercise tracker and then this is
going to create a directory containing
the default react project template with
all the dependencies installed so while
this is installing I'm actually gonna go
back over here to just talk a little bit
about a MongoDB object IDs so this
object ID is automatically generated by
the MongoDB driver and is guaranteed to
be unique across a collection so you can
see different parts of the object ID
represent different things and we can
define our own idea if we'd like but it
must be unique for each document in a
collection for this application I'm just
gonna let MongoDB handle it so let's go
back over to Visual Studio code and you
can see that our burnt exercise tracker
is all set up our react project so right
in the terminal let me just make this a
little bigger here right in the terminal
I'm going to do CD burn and go into the
directory there and normally if I want
to start a web server the the react web
the react development server we I would
type an NPM start here but first we're
going to create the backend and then
we're gonna come back to create the
front-end so we'll start by train the
backend and connecting it to MongoDB
Atlas and Google Cloud and then we'll
come back and write the react later so
inside this folder we are going to
create a new folder called back-end so a
lot of people would create the backend
in a separate folder from our front-end
folder but just to simplify things since
this since this is a simple project
we'll just create the back-end folder
right in our in our react front-end
folder so let's go into the backend
folder okay now we'll create a package
JSON file inside the folder by doing NPM
and knit and then why to answer yes to
all the questions asks okay now we can
install a few dependencies so MPM
install Express Korres Mongoose and dot
env okay so what are these packages
well we already discussed Express which
is a light and a lightweight and fast
web framework for nodejs cores stands
for cross origin resource sharing
and this allows Ajax requests to skip
the same-origin policy and access
resources from remote hosts the course
package provides an express middleware
that can enable cores with different
options which is this is going to make
it so we can easily access some
something outside of our server from our
server so also we already discussed
Mongoose which makes interacting with
MongoDB through node.js simpler and the
last one is notice a MV which loads it
loads environment variables from a DMV
file into process DMV this makes
development simpler so instead of
setting environment variables on our
development machine they can be stored
in a file will create a DMV file later
so we'll install one final package
globally so I'll do MPM install g4
globally and node mon-sol node man makes
development easier it's a tool that
helps develop nodejs based applications
by automatically restarting the node
application when files when file changes
in the directory are detective so let's
see it looks like we have some sort of
error I wonder what I oh I should do a
pseudo whenever you're going to install
something globally we'll do sudo install
G node mom so whenever we update our
server file it will automatically
restart the server so that's what node
mountain-man does so now it's time to
create our server so inside the backend
a folder I'm going to create a new file
called server a yes so I'm gonna start
I'm actually just gonna paste in some
code here and then I'll talk about what
the code is so first we're going to
require all the things we're going to
need actually we're not going to need
body parts
I originally thought would have any body
part sure but it's actually it's not
needed in the new version of Express and
this since we're it's included and
Express so I can actually change that to
express their so we're gonna we're just
going to need Express and cores and then
this configures so we can have our
environment variables in the DMV file
this is how we're going to create our
Express server and then you can see the
port that the server will be on then we
have our middleware so this is the cores
middleware and this is going to allow us
to parse JSON because our server is
going to be sending and receiving JSON
and then you can see this line here is
what starts the server it starts
listening on a certain port so once we
have that I can save this and I can
start the server so node Mon server
right in the terminal here so now we
have the server running you can see it
says server is running on port 5,000 so
now we've gotten to the point where we
can connect our database we can connect
to our database on MongoDB Atlas so at
the top of this server file after this
require cores line I'm going to add the
following line Const Mongoose equals
require Mongoose so Mongoose is what's
going to help us to connect to our
MongoDB database so now the next section
I'm actually just going to paste in here
so after we set up our middleware we're
going to do this so we have our URI
which is our database URI
this is something we have to get from
the MongoDB Atlas dashboard which we'll
do in a minute here so here [ __ ] stock
connect and we pass in the URI
that's where our database is stored and
that's how we start our connection so
you can see we have some flags here the
first one is added this new used new
user parser true that's added because
[ __ ] the MongoDB nodejs driver rewrote
the tool it uses to parse [ __ ] DB
connection strings and because this is
such a big change they put the new
connection string parser behind a flag
and it's kind of similar for this use
create index true it's to deal with a
[ __ ] D with MongoDB deprecating the
insurer index function you don't really
have to remember all that just put these
things in every time to deal with some
of the updates to MongoDB so for the
connection string to work we are going
to have to set this environment variable
so in the server folder first of all I
will save this and then we're gonna see
an error down here because we don't have
this environmental variable yet so I'm
going to go into my back-end folder and
I'm going to create a new file called
dot e and V so now we need to get the
URI or the connection string from
MongoDB Atlas so let me go over to that
here's MongoDB Atlas and I already have
the the cluster created so if I create
click connect here connect your app to
your application and I'm going to copy
the connection string so now I can go
back over to my file here and we just
have to create the environmental
variable so remember it's called Atlas
underscore URI and then I'm gonna set
what it's equal to and now I'm just
going to paste in the URI connection
here and one thing I have to do at the
beginning you'll see that there's this
password here so here I just
actually have to type in my password so
don't tell anybody what my password is
but it's mean
1 2 3 4 extra security I always have the
exact same password as my username no
that's not true you should never do that
but in this case that's what I'm doing
here so now we should if I save this and
then if I restart my server we should
see MongoDB right in the console
terminal MongoDB database connection
established successfully so we got that
right here so connection dot once so
once the connection is open it's going
to log that that MongoDB database
connection establish successfully so
we're now connected to the database but
now we have to start being able to put
things into the database and read things
from the database so we'll create our
database schema using Mongoose we'll
have two entities well it exercises and
users so inside the back-end folder I'm
going to create a new directory called
let's see what did I do wrong there new
folder called models and inside models
I'm going to create two new files so
well exercise model Jas and then I'm
going to create another file called user
model Jas
okay so for the user model I'm just
going to put some code and then I'll
explain what it is here so this user
schema you can see that first we require
Mongoose then we get a new mongoose
schema and so all mongoose schema start
basically the same and we have our user
schema that's the name and this
has a single field which is username
then we have some validations to the
username we know it's gonna be type
string it's required we know it has to
be unique trim means this little trim
whitespace off the end if someone types
in some spaces it will be trimmed off
and then max length or min length of
three so it has to be at least three
characters long so then we're going to
also include timestamps which will
automatically create fields for winner
was created and when it was modified and
then we just have Mongoose Top Model
user that can be anything that's just
that the name that we're gonna use then
user schema and then what's going to
order gonna export here so a lot of this
is going to look the same for any
Mongoose schema so I'm going to save
that and then we're going to do the
exercise model so you'll see the
exercise model is going to look almost
exactly the same with just a few changes
let's zoom out just a little bit so
everything is the same except this time
instead of one field we have four fields
now it takes up less space because the
validations are all on the same line as
the field and we don't have as many
validations so you can see we have user
name description duration and date so
this is all the information we're going
to store about the exercises and you can
see they're all required but we have
some different data types we have
strings
we have a number and then the date
datatype so now we have got we've got
those created and now we need to add the
API endpoint routes so the server can be
used to perform the crud application
operations which is create read update
and delete so inside this back-end
folder I'm going to create another
folder named routes
and inside that folder I'm going to
create a file called exercises J yes and
a file called users a s so we'll come
back to those files first we'll tell the
server to use the files we just created
so toward the end of this file right
before this app dot listen and we're
going to add some lines here so we have
to require the files and then use the
files so here we're requiring the files
and then basically we're just importing
them into here and then we're doing app
that used to use these files so now
whenever someone goes to our root URL
and then you put slash exercises at the
end it's going to load everything and
the exercise is router and if someone
goes to slash users it will load
everything in the users router now once
I show you this on the browser it will
probably make more sense so but so
you'll be seeing that soon so let's
build out the router files I'll save
that and then there's gonna be an error
here because we haven't actually built
out these router files yet let me go to
exercise J yes actually we'll start with
the users J yes okay I'll paste in some
code and then I'll explain it here so we
need the Express router because this is
a route that we're creating and here we
are going to require the model so this
is the Mongoose model that we created
that we just recently created and here
is our first route so this is the first
end point that handles incoming HTTP GET
requests on the slash users URL path so
we have our route
URL which is localhost I think localhost
5,000 so we have localhost 5,000 and
then it's slash users and then if it's
just a slash at the end slash user slash
then if it's a get request then this is
going to happen so it says users dot
find this is a Mongoose method that it's
going to get a list of all the users
from the MongoDB Atlas database the fine
method returns a promise so the results
are returned in JSON format and you can
see right here so after it finds then
we're going to get all the users and
then rest dot JSON means we're going to
return something in JSON format and what
we're in return are the users that we
got from the database and then if
there's an error dot catch we're going
to return a status 400 with an error
with just the error message here so the
second and the second endpoint handles
incoming HTTP POST requests you can see
it has slash ad on the end and it's a
post request then we'll handle those the
new username is part of the request body
so wrapped up body dot username is going
to be it is going to be assigned to this
username variable and then we're going
to create a new instance of user using
the username finally the new user is
saved to the database with the save
method right here and we return so then
after the user's saved to the database
the MongoDB Alice database then we'll
return user added in JSON or else we'll
return the error message so finally and
this is what you have to do for all just
a standard thing for
or these router files my module des
exports equals router so we're just
exporting the router so let me save that
and I'll go into the exercises file and
I'm going to paste some code in here and
these are the same two endpoints so it's
gonna be basically the same we're
requiring router we're requiring our
model that we created so if it's now
it's if it's the root URL slash
exercises slash at the end if it's a get
request then we're gonna run this
Mongoose command exercise that find then
after we find all the exercises from the
database well take those exercises and
then return them as JSON or else there's
an error so this part is a little
different but it's it's basically the
same as before if we have exercises
slash ad and it's a post request then
instead of just having a username in the
body we're going to have the username
will have description the duration and
the date and we'll sign up to these
variables and you can see that we're
converting the duration to a number and
we're converting the date to a date
datatype and then we just create a new
exercise using all of these variables
that we got up here and then we save the
exercise and after it's saved
dot then it's a promise we're gonna
return the JSON exercise added we'll add
some more API endpoints soon but first
let's test the server api we'll be using
a tool called insomnia to test the API
another popular tool for this purpose is
postman they both do pretty much the
same thing so once you get into insomnia
or you could use postman we'll create a
new post request using JSON so I'll do a
post request and all this stuff can be
changed on the next screen here so we
have this post REE
Qwest and we'll go to the URL HTTP colon
slash slash localhost 5,000 slash users
slash
and now we should still have our server
running so in the body I will select
JSON and we are going to send a username
we're gonna add a username so I'm going
to create this JSON object here username
bow and if I click post here oh I mean
I'm going to click send and it says user
added so now we can send a get request
to get a list of the users back so first
let me just add another user so I'll
just do Quincy here and send that and
user added so now we can do a get
request to get the list of users back so
instead of users slash
add it will just be user slash without
the add at the end I'll change this post
to get and we don't need this here and
I'll just click send and you can see our
users here with some additional
information here so you can see MongoDB
automatically created this object ID and
then we also have the created at and
updated at date here so we have the
username Bo and the used username Quincy
so we can also see the users we just
added on the MongoDB Atlas dashboard so
let me go over to that so here is the
MongoDB Atlas dashboard cloud MongoDB
calm so if I click refresh here we
should see yep we see our users here so
if you were back on this screen you
would have to click collections and then
it's going to load our users here and
then if you see in this documents we
have beau and Quincy so these are the
exact
the users that we added so we've
successfully created our back-end that
can put items into our MongoDB Atlas
database okay let's add a few exercises
so let me go back over here so instead
of slash users it's going to be slash
exercises and then it's gonna be slash
and so just so you see how this is all
working I'll go back over to our code
editor and when you go to slash ad you
exercise the slash ad and do a post
request it's going to be expecting a
user name a description a duration and
the date it's gonna be expecting
variables in our JSON object that have
all of those keys or all those names and
then it's going to take all those things
and it's going to save an exercise so
let's go back over to insomnia and in
JSON we need a username and set that to
Beau and then we need a description and
we'll set that to run and then for
duration and the duration is in minutes
which you'll see once we create our our
front-end we'll do nine minutes and for
date I'm actually just going to copy
this date from over here once we create
our front-end you'll never have to
actually enter a date because you'll be
just selecting a date from a drop-down
menu but since we're entering it
directly into the database we'll just
copy and paste
so if I click send we should see o
cannot get because I forgot to change
this to a post request our server did
not have anything for a get request to
that URL but let's try a post request
okay exercise andddd well let's add one
more exercise which is going to be a
bike ride same username and this time it
was for 30 minutes and
I'll change this to let's see 27 and if
I just send that we just added another
exercise so we can do a get request if I
just fleet slash add change this to dot
get and then click send now we did we
sent this JSON but it just didn't do
anything with it it's okay to send it
it's just extra didn't do anything with
it but you can see over here we have our
two exercises we added so username buh
description run duration nine we have
the date same down here we have a bike
ride and if we go over to MongoDB Atlas
and then I'm just gonna click refresh go
into the exercises and you can see
here's the two exercises we added so and
right from here you can actually do some
editing like if I want to say actually
this was sixty minutes that I can update
and so we're able to easily update we
can delete things you can do all sorts
of changes right from this dashboard
here so that makes things that's nice it
kind of makes things simpler so now that
we've tested everything we'll finish up
the exercise routes so let me go back
into the code editor we're actually done
with the users routes all we're gonna
have is to get an ad now in like a real
production app you would have up you
would have a update and a delete for now
we'll just do that from the MongoDB
Atlas dashboard but for the exercises we
will have everything well we're gonna
have all the Col crud we'll have delete
update and that's what we're gonna add
now I am going to right here I'm going
to paste them the other route and then
I'll talk about them here
so we just add this route we have a
slash : ID so this : ID is like a
variable so this is a manga this is an
Eydie that's created automatically by
MongoDB so if you go to exercise as
slash and then put the object ID from
the database and then you do a get
request well we're going to return just
the information about that
exercise so we have exercised that find
by ID and then the request that params
the ID so this is getting the ID
directly from the URL here and we're
finding by that ID and then once we get
the exercise we're going to return it as
JSON or else we are going to just return
an error so then the next thing is going
it starts off the same so this was the
get request and this looks exactly the
same but instead of get its delete so if
you pass in the object ID but it's a
delete request instead of a get request
it's going to do find by ID and delete
again it's going to get it right from
the URL here and it will delete it from
the database so it says dot then after
it's deleted it's going to return
exercise deleted so the next one is the
update so if the route is exercises /
update / ID so the object ID and it's
that post then we're going to update it
so first we have to find the current
exercise and then we update it so
exercise that find by ID and we pass in
the parameter right from the URL here so
after we get the exercises dot then and
then we what we're going to do with the
exercise is well we're going to take the
exercise that username so this is the
exercise we just got from the database
but we're gonna set the username to
equal wrap that body that username
because it's going to have this route
needs to receive a a JSON object that's
going to create that's going to contain
a username a description a duration and
a date
just like when you're adding a new
to a new exercise but this time we're
taking all the information and assigning
it to the fields of the exercise that
already exists and then we're gonna save
that exercise with the new information
and then we're going to return exercise
updated so now that we've seen all these
end points let's go and test these other
ones so I'll go right back over here and
let's test the first end point we added
so first we need to get an ID I'm just
going to copy this ID right from here
and then we'll have slash exercises
slash ID and this is going to be a get
request if I send this it will just
return a single exercise so before it
returned all the exercises but now that
we have this new route where it's
localhost 5,000 slash exercises slash
the ID is going to return just the first
exercise that corresponds to that ID the
next thing where that trial is the we're
gonna try editing it so slash exercises
slash update and then so we have slashed
exercises slash update and then we have
the ID here I wonder if I can here now
we'll be let's see more of it exercises
slash update slash ID and this is going
to be a post this is the one where the
description is run from before it has to
receive a user name description duration
and date so the new description instead
of run from what it was before it's
going to be walk and the duration is now
going to be how about 120 and then we'll
keep the date the same so I'm going to
copy this date and paste it in here so
right now the way the program works is
that you always have to send it the user
name description duration and date you
cannot just stand
and the feel that you want to update you
always have to send all the fields or
there'll be an error now that's
something that you can refactor later is
make it so you can just receive one of
the items instead of all of them but for
now we just have a setup for you it has
to accept every single field so if I
post this and then I'm going to change
this into a get request and take out the
update you can see that the same ID now
has a description of walk and a duration
of 120 but actually we don't even want
that anymore so we are going to delete
it instead of sitting at the get request
I will send a delete and then if I send
that exercise deleted so now I'm just
going to go to the URL the route that
returns all of the exercises so just
slash exercises slash and then a get
request and you'll see that now we just
have one exercise whereas before we had
two one of them's been deleted so we
just have the one ok now that we've
tested this we're actually done with the
back end we just had a simple back end
with some crud routes so now it's time
to start the front end before we get
into our front end code let's talk a
little bit about react now I'm just
going to give a brief overview of react
if you want a full in-depth tutorial you
can check out the react to toriel on the
free code camp YouTube channel react is
a declarative efficient and flexible
Java Script library for building user
interfaces it lets you compose complex
user interfaces from small and isolated
pieces of code called components now our
project isn't too complex but it's still
gonna give you a good introduction to
react we use components to tell react
what we want to see on the screen so
this is an example of a type of
component right here and when our data
changes react will efficiently update
and re-render our components so this is
a react component class you can see it
says react dot component that's what
this extends here and a component takes
in parameters called props short for
properties and it returns a hierarchy of
views to display through the render
method so you can see we have a render
method here and then it's returning
something here the render method returns
a description of what you want to see on
the screen it takes a description and
displays the result it returns a react
element which is a lightweight
description of what to render this
syntax here it kind of looks like HTML
but it's actually a special syntax
called JSX
which makes the structures easier to
write so this is actually converted into
HTML when it goes through pre-processing
and J Access X comes with the full power
of JavaScript you can put any JavaScript
expressions within braces so you can see
this bracelet these braces where it says
this dot props that name this is getting
the the props account like a variable
and you can see the example usage so to
call this react component or to place on
the page you'll use something like we
have at the bottom so we have the name
of the react component and then we pass
in the props name equals Bo so right in
what we're returning when it says this
dot props that name it's going to put Bo
so on the page it will return shopping
list for Bo so another common difference
between JSX and HTML is instead of class
we have class name but for the most part
you can write JSX just like you would
write HTML so let's go to the code so
remember earlier we did create react app
that created our whole
react project I'm going to close some of
this back-end code because we're not
gonna use that right now because we're
working on the front end so right now
I'm gonna go over some of what the front
end code so if I go to the source
directory and then we're gonna go into
actually let's start in public and it
will go to the the index.html so this is
the HTML page that loads when you go to
our website so let me kind of explain
this you can see how react works with it
so for one we don't need any of this
these comments so delete that so it's
easier to see what's going on here and
you can see this line right here is
where our react is going our react app
is gonna load it says div id equals root
and you'll see in our JavaScript we are
going to load our react app right into
that div well the only thing we really
need to change here is the title so
instead of react app I will call this
exercise tracker and save that and then
if we go into our JavaScript that loads
with our HTML it's right here so this is
our basic JavaScript file that loads and
you can see it's going to load react
react Dom the index that CSS we are not
writing any custom CSS so we can get rid
of that importing app this is where
we're actually going to create our file
our this is basically the the starting
point where we're gonna within the app
dot j/s that we import it here and
that's where we're going to create our
front-end react amp and you can see down
here this is the main thing that renders
our amp react on that render it's going
to render our app which is what we're
going to be working on next and it's
going to put it here document dot get
element by ID root that's what we were
just looking at in the HTML file the
root here so we're loading our app into
that element so we're not going to use
serviceworker so it
delete some of this stuff when you can
delete that when you use create react
app it sometimes gives you some extra
things that you don't need so let's go
into the app Jas
that's this file here so this is our
main app our main component our main
react app that we're gonna put all of
our code that will display on the page
and actually let's get this started so
we can see what this looks like right
now I'm going to open up a new terminal
window window so in this new terminal
window I'm just going to switch into
their art directory the X exercise
tracker directory and O'Byrne exercise
tracker and then I'm just going to do
MPM start okay so this is going to start
our app and it will load right here
right on localhost 3000 and here is our
react app you can see it says edit
source slash app to save and save to
reload so it's going to hot reload or
automatically reload this page anytime
we make some changes so what I'm going
to do here is just do some basic changes
here so let's see what we're gonna do we
we're not going to use this logo we're
not going to use this CSS here and let's
just return something basic instead of
what we have here I'm going to delete
all this and we're just going to return
it's just when I say hello world and for
the classname app I'll just call it
container so if I save this and I go
back over to my browser it says hello
world and so anything that we change
here and update here you will see
automatically on the page so you can see
this is being returned this JSX which
gets loaded into our HTML with this
javascript file and it appears on our
page so
now let's add the bootstrap CSS
framework to our project to make styling
easier so I'm going to open up a new
terminal tab and I will do MPM install
bootstrap
okay well that's installing I will go up
here and I am going to import bootstrap
so import bootstrap this last distance
less CSS slash bootstrap man dot CSS so
we have bootstrapped imported now and
now let's set up react router the react
router so I'll do MPM install react
router Dom okay react router is going to
make it easier to route different URLs
to different react components you'll see
how it works as we go along here so I'm
going to have to import it so right at
the top right after we import react this
time I'm just going to paste in a line
here import we're importing browser
router as router and route from react
router Dom okay now we can create a
router element so now that we're
importing this router from router
reactive Dom we have to put everything
that we want to be used with the router
inside a router element so what I'm
going to do here is do router and then
at the end we will put the closing
router tag and then now instead of our
hello world we're going to update it to
the to start actually building the
actual app here so I'm just going to
paste in some information here and
you'll see that we have a router element
for each route of the application so we
have a few components these are all
components that were still
going to create we have the navbar
component exercise list component an
exercise create exercise and create user
component so these components we still
have to create here and you'll see that
there's a route element for each route
in the application the path attribute is
set to the URL path so if you go to our
route URL with a slash at the end it
will load this component if you go to
the root URL slash edit and then we have
an ID this is the [ __ ] DB object ID
we'll go to the Edit exercise component
or the create component or the user the
create user component depending on which
path so that's what react router does is
it helps us map specific URL paths to
different components that will load on
the page so we're gonna have to create
those five components and we'll create
them in separate files
but first let's import the files we're
just about to create into a BAS right
after the import for bootstrap so right
after this I will import all these let's
add some semicolons and so you see that
we're importing these are the names of
the different components and these are
just where they're located components of
navbar doc component component slash
exercise list that component with these
files were just about to create you can
see they're all in the components
directory so that's what we'll create
now so inside the same directory as a
pas inside the source directory I'm
going to create a new folder and it's
gonna be called components so inside
this components folder I'm going to
create a new file called nav bar dot
component a yes I'm just going to paste
in this code here and then I will go
over a little bit
so most react components are going to
start with the start the same you're
always going to import
and component from react and then since
we're using react router I'm going to
import link that's going to allow us to
link to different routes and then all
components start like this export
default class navbar that's the name of
the component extends component and all
components have to render something so
we're gonna render this return statement
and this code right here is basically
just the navbar from the bootstrap
documentation converted to work for our
purposes you'll see that instead of
class we have class name the links
instead of an anchor tag we use this
link from react router but it's going to
show up the same way as as just a link
on there and we show which what we're
going to link to here and the different
URLs we're gonna link to and then we
have special classes just a style using
bootstrap styles so you can always just
check out the bootstrap documentation if
you want to learn more about the Styles
you can do with that so at this point
we're going to create our other
component files so I'm going to create
exercises list component j/s I'm going
to create edit exercises dot component J
yes
then we'll have create exercise that
component dot J yes then create user dot
component J s and those are all of our
component files right now we're just
going to create stubs for these
components just so we can see if
everything works so far so in the
exercises list component just put in
this this is just some basic just the
most basic component you can have
important reaction component export
default class exercise list component
extends component and then we're just
going to render you are on the exercise
list component so I'm just going to copy
this code and go into the Edit exercise
component I'll paste that in and the
exercises list we're gonna do edit
exercises and again instead of you were
on the exercises list component I'll
just you you are on the edit exercises
component and I'll copy that again let
me make sure that this is saved and here
instead of exercises list wait I meant
to copy yeah copy this it'll be easier
to start with this one instead of edit
exercise it's gonna be create I'm just
gonna select edit and do command D to
select two places at once and then I can
just type in two places at once and I'll
put the word create in both spots so
I'll save that and then our create user
component so again I'm actually going to
copy this code paste it in here instead
of create exercises command D I'm going
to do create users so you want to create
users component the last thing I need to
do is save fjs and now we should be able
to test this out so let me go over to
the browser ooh
failing to compile I see what happened
this is the wrong type of quotation mark
so there we go
[Music]
and let me go back over there cannot
resolve create user component here is
where I may have just spelled something
wrong let's see component oh yeah I just
spelled this run wrong so let me rename
that's why it's good to test every once
in a while while you're building things
just to make sure everything is working
let's see it's looking for an exercise
and I just put s at the end of this so
let's take that off and now we're gonna
work and it's working so it says you are
on the exercise list component when we
click the different things exercise you
are on the exercise list component click
here you are on the create exercise
component and then click here you are on
the create user component and I'm back
on fjs and there was one thing I want to
improve just to use the styling better
from bootstrap inside this router I'm
gonna have a div and we'll set the class
name to equal container and then we just
need a closing div here at the end and
then I'll just indent this a little bit
so let's see what that looks like now
okay I think that looks a little better
so we have some space on the sides and
everything's are just a little more
centered okay
let's start creating our first component
so we already created the stubs of the
components and now we're gonna create
the create exercise component
so here's create exercise that component
so this will allow us to add exercises
into the database we're going to at
first add a constructor so right here
I'm going to add the constructor here
and what you're going to do constructor
props and in Java and JavaScript classes
you need to always call super when
defining the constructor of a subclass
so we're gonna do that
all react component classes they have a
constructor should start with a super
props call we'll set the initial state
of the component by assigning an object
to this that state
so do this state equals and we need a
property we're going to create
properties of the state that will
correspond to the fields of the MongoDB
document so we'll have username equals
empty string description oh that's not
socially an equal sign that's supposed
to be a colon there let me fix that and
then we'll have duration well start this
as zero because it's a number and then
the final thing is the date which is
going to be a new date and then these
are all the parts of the database via
but we're also going to have something
right just for this component called
users and you'll see how we're going to
use that in a minute here so state is
are basically how you create variables
and react you're never gonna do
something like let name equal Bo or
something like that
so in react you're always gonna create
anything in state so whenever you update
the state it will automatically update
your page with the new values so users
the reason why we have the users array
here is because on our page
there's gonna be a drop down menu where
you can select all the users that are
already in the database you can select a
user to associate with your exercise so
now we need to add methods which can be
used to update the state properties so
at the end of our constructor I'm going
to add a method here on change user name
and I'm going to pass an e I'll explain
the e just in a moment here but when the
user name is being changed we're going
to set the state so to set if we want to
set the here something you will never do
you're not going to do this dot state
that username
equals and then put in what the new
username is you always want to use the
set state property or the step set state
method here and react and inside here we
can set just the item we're going to
change username is going to equal a dot
target dot value so this is going to be
called in we're gonna have a webform
where there's going to be a text box
where someone enters the username so
whenever someone enters a username it's
going to call this function and it's
going to set the state eat up target
value well the target is the text box
and this is the value of the text box so
it's going to set the value of user name
to whatever the value was in that text
box now if we just said we're just
setting user name it doesn't necessarily
it's not going to put all the rest of
our state to nothing it doesn't replace
state with just this it just updates
this element within the state it's just
going to update the username element
within the state so we need to do the
same thing for all of our other ones so
let's I'm just paste in here I'm gonna
change things so I'll change user name
is gonna be unchanged description and
then there's gonna be a description
unchanged this is going to be duration
and it's going to be duration and then
we have date and then we have date here
now this one's going to be a little
different we're gonna use a library to
make a calendar that appears and you can
click the date on the calendar so we're
gonna pass in the date here and we're
just gonna set it with the date that's
passed in after those methods we will
add one to handle the submit event on
the form so we're you'll see the form at
the end of all this and it's creating
these methods to handle the form first
so on
mint when someone clicks the submit
button this is what we're gonna do first
when we eat up prevent default so this
will prevent the default HTML form
submit behavior from taking place so
instead of doing what it would normally
would have done it's going to do what
we're about to define here so I have a
Const of an exercise and remember I said
you'll never just create variables
normally and react well that's inside a
single method you can create variables
if they're only going to be used within
that method so
exercise equals and then we're just
going to set everything so the user name
is going to be this dot state dot user
name and the description is going to be
this that state that description and
then we have duration is going to be
this dot state that duration and then
date is going to be this that state dot
date so for now all we're going to do
with this exercise is do a console dot
log console dot log exercise now
eventually this is going to be the part
where we submit the exercise to the
database but we're just going to finish
up a little bit of our front-end first
and then we're going to connect our
front end to the back end so after this
the user the exercise has been submitted
we'll just do window dot location equals
slash so we're just going to take the
person back to our home page which is
going to be the list of exercises so
once you submit an exercise it will go
back to the list of exercises so now we
just have to make sure that this the
word this works properly in our methods
so if we see the word where says this
dot set state this set state
if we were to do a console that log this
within this method we would see that
this is undefined so we need to make
sure that when it says this inside a
method this we know what this is
referring to and we want this to refer
to the class this whole class so what we
have to do is up here I'm going to paste
in some code here and it says this the
unchanged username equals this the
unchanged username that bind dot this so
we're binding this to each of these
methods so the word this will be
referring to the right thing we're just
about to add the form that people that
will allow people to enter exercises but
first we must add one final method
people filling out the form like I was
mentioning earlier they're going to
select the user associated with the
exercise from a drop-down list
eventually the user list will come
directly from the MongoDB database for
now though we'll hard-code a single user
so let's add a method here this is going
to be a component did mount now this is
a react lifecycle method so there's a
few lifecycle methods and react that
react will automatically call at
different points so component did mount
will automatically be called right
before anything displays on the page so
when this create exercise component is
about to load to the page right before
anything loads it's going to run this
code so what we're gonna do here is do
this that set state and we are going to
set the state of our users array so
users is going to equal now here we're
just doing a test user eventually we
will load this directly from the
database but we're doing one step at a
time here and we also want to set the
username to test user the drop-down menu
will automatically have the first user
in the drop-down selected so we want the
user name
be set to that user right at the very
beginning the final thing we needed to
do not the final thing we need to do is
to add the form code so I'm just about
to paste the form code in here right at
the bottom and then I'll kind of just go
over it here I'm going to paste that in
and yeah so this is just a pretty
standard HTML form we have our heading
create new exercise log on submit when
you submit it's going to call the Vista
on submit so you can see we have these
curly braces and we can put in
JavaScript or different methods and so
we can say that we're gonna call the
Vista on submit when someone clicks that
button so we have our username which is
just this is a drop-down menu so in this
drop-down menu we're gonna set the value
to this dot state dot username and then
on change whenever you change the the
selection this Don change username now
this is where we do something a little
fancy so inside a slick box we have
different options and we're getting the
options right from our users array so
you can see we have the curly braces
which means we can put some JavaScript
in here and it says this that state dot
users which is an array of all the users
which will come from our MongoDB Atlas
database dot map that map allows us to
return something for each element in an
array so we have this function now this
could also be an arrow function if we
were going to refactor but for now it's
just a regular function so it's going to
take a user so for each user in the
array it's going to return this it's
going to return an option which is an
option of the select box and in this
option we have a key which is the user a
value which is the user and then the
actual text that will appear which is
also the user and then we have the
description which is just a standard
input box but we set the value and we
set the on
change method to be called anytime this
has changed we have duration which is in
minutes like I mentioned before so we
have the value the unchanged method now
the date is going to be a little
different we have a date method a date
picker component which we still have to
add so this date picker component is
going to pop up a calendar where you can
select an actual date so we put what the
initial selection is and what happens
when you change that selection so this
is going this date picker component we
are actually going to install a package
with NPM so we don't have to create
ourselves this is already a package that
exists so down in the terminal will do
MPM install react date picker and while
that's installing we are going to have
to put in a line to import it at the top
so right the top I'm going to put in two
lines after we import react we're gonna
import date picker from react date
picker and then align to import the
styling for that date picker so at this
point we can actually test this so I'm
going to save this and we'll go back
over to our browser and I'm going to
create click create exercise log so it
says create new exercise log I'm gonna
open up my browser for on a Mac its
command option J if you're on Chrome but
it may be something different and by I'm
said I think it said open my browser I
meant open my console so I'm gonna open
my JavaScript console whoops did not
mean to click that okay I'm gonna open
up my JavaScript console and you'll see
when I clicks when I create something so
I'll select test user
I'll put run I'll put 10 for 10 minutes
and then we'll just here's the date
picker I was talking about so we can
select a date here and if I click creat
exercise log you'll see it two things
happened first it logged it to the
console here
get CSS test user description run
duration 10 and we have the date that we
put in here and then right after it
logged it
we got taken back to our exercise list
component so you can see with a
bootstrap that makes it responsive to
different sizes here
so the exercise list component we still
have to create but eventually it will
show all the exercises that are in the
database okay now that we've created
that component and we've tested it out
we are going to create the create user
component so let me go over to the
create user component and we are going
to have another constructor so actually
this constructor is buddy
kind of similar I'm gonna start by just
copying this constructor from the create
exercise component and then putting it
in the create user component but this
time we're only going to have an
unchanged user name and then an on
submit button our state is only going to
have a user name like that and then just
like our other thing we're going to have
a unchanged user name method and we will
have an on submit method which is gonna
be pretty similar so I'm just going to
copy and paste just like before so when
it's just going to be a simple web form
with just a user name field and then
once this is submitted we're instead of
exercise we're gonna call it user and
then we're just going to have the user
name and I'm going to console dot log
the user and this time instead of now
changing the location back to the home
page we will do we'll just keep the user
on this page so they can enter multiple
users at a time so to do that we have to
do this that set state and we have to
set the user name to blank because after
someone's already entered the user we
should have we
should set it back to blank so they can
enter another username now just like I
said before we are eventually going to
make this connect to the database but
for now we're just going to set the
state just like that so let's see if I
see this is grayed out here I don't know
exactly what's wrong types this set
state you know I don't think anything's
wrong so I don't know why it's giving us
this err let's just test it out and see
what happens but first we're going to
have to add our code for our form so I'm
going to go to the render so what we're
gonna render here is just a very simple
web form that has one field so it says
create new user there's a submit button
and then we just have one input box with
a value of username and unchanged it's
on change username so if I save this we
can go back over into our browser and oh
I see what I did wrong there so I just
put this in the wrong order so that
should be parentheses and then brackets
and then I can just take this up to here
and get rid of that okay so now we
should be able to save it okay so we
already tested create user name let me
clear the console here now we're going
to test create user so if I type in bow
and click create user it will show up in
the console and then this is blank so we
can enter another user so that works
so now we can submit users and it shows
up in the console we're now going to
work on connecting the front end to the
back end so far the front end in the
back end of our app are separate so
we're gonna be connecting the do two
together by causing our front end to
send HTTP requests to the server end
points on the
back end will use the Axios library to
send the HTTP request to our back-end so
in our terminal we'll install that NPM
install
Axios and now we'll complete the
implementation of the create user
component and send data to the backend
so at the very top of the create user
component I'm going to import
Axios from Axios and then we just have
to go down to the submit button so in
the submit button right after console
dot log will still log the user but now
we are going to send the user data to
our back-end so I'll do Axios dot post
and then we'll we have to put in the the
URL so it's HTTP colon slash slash
localhost 5,000 slash users slash ad and
then I just do a comma user so after we
post that we'll do a dot then so this is
going to be a promise so after it's
posted then we're going to do something
and what we're going to do is take the
result and we're going to do console dot
log res data so you can see this extra
step that's going to send an HTTP POST
request to this back-end endpoint and
it's going to the endpoint is expecting
a JSON object in the request body and
that's what we do here we send that as
as a second argument so let me just go
into our back-end so you can actually
see what that looks like in the backend
I think I'm going to have to open that
file again the server's a
or actually it's the in the routes the
users j/s so this is the route we're
doing so we're sending a get request or
a post request to user slash ad and it's
going to expect in the body request that
body that username the username and then
we create a new user and we save the
user so now that we have this done we
can just save it and we can test things
out I will create a new user Mary in the
new create user user added and right now
if I add a user that's already in the
database like Bo we'll see an error
right in the log now something to do to
refactor later would be to handle this
err differently but right now we're not
gonna do anything about that we're just
going to have the air in the log because
it won't accept any duplicate username
so if we go into MongoDB Atlas the
dashboard and I click refresh we should
see the meri username so now we see user
name Mary and it's been added to our
database so we got that working let's go
back over to the code and let's start
completing the implementation of the
create exercise component so go over to
the kree exercise component at the very
top
just like before we are going to import
Axios from Axios and then we I'm going
to do an axe your step post right and on
submit so it's actually gonna look very
similar to the create user one so I just
copy this and bring it over here
right after we log the exercise we will
post it but instead of slash users it's
going to be slash exercise instead of
user it's going to be exercise and then
we'll just log the result to the
console which would be exercise added so
you can see right and let's go over to
the back end again when it gets this
route the post route and then we have
the ad will get all the information from
the body we create the new exercise and
then we send the JSON exercise added and
that's what will show up in the console
with the console dot log rest data so
we're not quite ready to test this out
because we still need to update our
component will mount method so if you
remember we have a drop-down menu where
you can select users and it should show
all the users that have currently been
added to the database in the drop-down
menu so I'm just going to cut this code
out here and right now we are going to
do another Axios but this time is gonna
be Axio stat get we're gonna send a get
request to HTTP colon slash last local
host 5,000 slash users and after we do
the request dot then we are going to
take the response will pass into this
arrow function and now we want to check
if there is a response
so if response dot data dot length is
more than 0 so basically checking that
there's at least one user in the
database and if so then we can I'm just
going to paste in that set state that I
cut out before but we're going to not
use this sample data anymore I'm gonna
put response dot data dot map so map is
so data is going to be an array and
we're going to map the array which will
allow us to return something for every
element in the array so what we're going
to return
user and well pass in the each user in
the array we're gonna return user dot
username so to kind of explain that
we're its user dot user name let's go
back over to MongoDB analyst dashboard
so the array of users is going to be
each of these items so this is the first
item in the array this is a second item
in the array this is the third item in
the array but we just want the user name
field so if we go back over here instead
of getting everything all those
different fields that's why we're just
going to return user dot user name
because we don't we don't care about the
object ID or the created or updated at
date for this so for the user name this
is going to be response data and then
I'll do the zero index of the array the
first element in the array dot user name
okay so user name is automatically set
to the first user in the database that's
what we just did so now we can test this
out so I can go back over here and go
back to the exercise tracker so I will
do a let's see exercise Cree exercise
log so look now it's showing a drop down
menu of every name from our array we're
getting this right from our array so I
will choose meri and for the description
i will put bike ride and then the
duration sixty five minutes and then the
date just click add it here and then
create exercise log okay it's good thing
we're testing it out because i just
realized this post URL is wrong it's
supposed to be exercises with a plural
here so let's try that one more time go
to create exercise log meri bike ride
sixty five and choose a date and good we
don't see an air in here so now i can go
and check out my
the atlas and then we'll see we have the
exercises here so go to the exercises
and this is one we already had but if we
go to the bottom now we have Mary Mary
bike ride duration 65 and the date that
we entered great this seems to be
working okay now we will complete the
exercise list component so let's go to
the exercise list component right here
so this is still a stub this is going to
show every exercise that has been added
to the database and this will be the
homepage of our app so at the very
beginning we are going to import some
things we're already importing react but
I am also going to import link from
reactor Dom and then I'm going to import
Axios so now we're going to start with a
constructor to initialize the state with
an empty exercises array so we'll do a
constructor props and we are going to
first do super props you always start
with super props and then before we
waited a method and then I would bind
this to the method but this time we'll
do in the other way around so we know
we're going to create a method called
delete exercise because in the list of
exercises we are going to have you're
going to be able to click a button to
delete the exercise so we're gonna do
bind this and then I just have to
initialize the state so if this dot
state is going to be equal to and since
there's not only going to be one item
I'm going to just put all in one line
it's going to be exercises and that's
just going to be an empty array of
exercises so we got that now we're going
to get that list of exercises from the
database so we're going to do that in a
component
did mount method just like before when
we got the list of users from the
database we're gonna get the list of
exercises from the database so we'll do
Axios get and then I'll just put HTTP
colon slash last local host 5,000 slash
exercises slash and then we'll do a dot
VIN and we'll take the response and we
will do this dot set state and before
wait let me just finish this exercises
is going to be response dot data so
before when we were getting the the user
names we did that we got just the user
name field and because we didn't want to
return all the fields but in this case
we do want all the fields for the
exercises so we are just going to get
the object ID that user name the
description duration date created yet
updated we're going to get all of this
stuff and we're going to put it into the
exercises are right here so after this
we are going to just catch any errors
that there's that what we would have so
we have error and let's see we'll just
consult that log the air if there's an
error and I think there's a few other
places where I could have also gotten
erred that I make me a missed but we
have this here so the code will run
before the page is rendered and add the
list of exercises to the state and so we
got the ex-ceo stat get endpoint that's
going to get all the exercises from here
so if we go to the exercises here so
here let's go to that get endpoint
that's just this one right here so when
we go to the exercises slash and it's a
get request we'll do exercise that find
which is going to return all the X
sizes and return it as JSON and now we
have in will get it here and what we
will set the state so this component
like I said will also allow users to
delete exercises so let's create the
method for that so this time I'm just
going to paste in the code and then I
will explain it I'll do it right after
this
we have delete exercise and it's going
to take an ID so this is the object ID
that we will be deleting the object ID
that MongoDB automatically assigns to
the thing that we're going to be leading
so we have Axios delete we're saying a
delete request to this URL slash ID it's
going to put the ID at the end remember
this is an exact route that we created
in the backend so once that happens we
are going to do a dot then and we're
just going to a log that it's been
deleted it will say exercise deleted
that we get right from the backend so
after we delete the exercise on the
database we also have to delete the
exercise from what's being displayed to
the user so it's going to be a table and
there's going to be a row for each
exercise and we want to delete that
element that item right from the table
so we can do that this is what a react
makes makes things really easy so we're
just going to set the state and we're
going to set the state of exercises and
whenever you do is set state it will
automatically react will automatically
update the page with that new state so
look how this is going to work
this that state that exercises that's
the array of exercises and now we're
going to filter it that means we are
only going to return certain elements
back to exercises here and this is what
we're going to do so for every element
in the exercises array we are going to
return it if L dot underscore ID does
not equal ID so whenever the ID of
the exercise in this exercises array
does not equal the idea that we're
deleting we'll pass it back to the
exercises array so this is just a way to
just remove the exercise that we're
deleting so you may be wondering where
does this underscore ID come from we've
just been using ID we've never made an
underscore ID well if we go back to the
MongoDB dashboard you'll see that the
underscore ID is automatically created
so the ID in the database is underscore
ID and that's just created automatically
when we create the object so after this
we can what we're going to update the
return statement of the render function
so this is where we create the JSX
or like it's similar to HTML that's
going to display on the page so I'll
just paste this in here let me so you
can see here we have our heading and
this is going to be a table and then
this is just a styling from bootstrap
and then we have all our user name
description duration day actions or
headers and then this is where it gets
interesting the body it's going to call
that method it's going to call the
exercise list method which we need to
implement and that's going to return the
rows of the table so directly above this
I'm going to paste in the method here
exercise list so it's calls this the
exercise list and exercise list it's
going to return this this dot state that
exercises dot map murder dot map is
going to return something for every
element in the array so for every
element called current exercise it's
going to return a component so this
exercise component is something that we
are just about to create so for every
element and the exercise array it's
going to return a component and that
component is basically going to be a row
of the table and we're gonna pass in
some
there's two props or actually three
props so we're passing in let me make
some more room here so we're gonna pass
in the current exercise so these are
basically you can think of them as
variable so here's the variable name
here's the value so we passing in the
current exercise we're passing in the
delete exercise method here and then
we're gonna pass in the key which is the
just current I exercise dot I D so this
exercise component let me just put in
this exercise component and then I'll
talk a little bit more about it so I'm
gonna put in up here above the other
component so now this one file actually
has two components in it we have this
exercises list that can play s that's
the file and we have two components we
have the exercises list component and we
have the exercise component right above
here there are two types of components
in this file now the exercise component
is implemented as a functional react
component and here this is implemented
as a class component you'll see the word
class here
so the key thing that makes a functional
react component different from a class
component is the lack of state and life
cycle methods so we don't have a state
we don't have a component didn't mount
life cycle method so if all you need to
do is to accept props and return JSX you
should use a functional component
instead of a class component and you can
see that for most of the components in
our app we have a separate file but
since this is such a small component
we've just put it in the same file in
the exercise list component jjs so let's
look at what this component is doing
it's accepting the props which are the
props or passed into it like exercise
elite exercise and the key
here and so it's going to return a row
of the table a table row so we have
props that exercise that username and
where the exercise goes past in props
actually that's a description duration
date and you can see with a substring
here that's because the day is a full
date/time string that includes date time
and time zone and we just want the first
part of it which is just the date part
so now we have a link we're using the
link from react rider Dom so it's going
to it's going to link to a certain URL
which is just going to load another
component on the page so we're gonna go
to the edit so it's edit / props that
exercise the ID so this is a component
that we still have to create that we're
creating next to edit the Edit exercise
component and then we're also going to
have a delete button
it's a delete link and so on click once
you delete once you click that it's
going to call this prop SOT delete
exercise so we've just passed in the
method from the other component that
delete exercise method is right here but
we've passed into this other component
and so we can actually delete that
exercise here and so it's going to call
down here the delete exercise component
or that go here where it's going to send
a call to the database or to the backend
which connects to the database you can
see these squiggly lines here
it's just notifying us of best practice
technically the best practice here would
be to use a button and style it as a
link but in this case we're just going
to do like this if you want to refactor
it later you can style this as a but
that you can create a button instead of
a link here but because the href isn't
going to anything the best practice
would be to make this a button like I
said we're not going to take the time to
do that right now
so now we've finished this but before we
test it out we are going to create the
Edit exercise component now the editors
sighs component is very similar to the
create exercise component in fact I'm
going to start by just copying all this
code and then just pasting it in here
now another thing you could do for
refactoring is you could actually
combine both of these into a single
component and then just update things
with the props based on what's going how
it's going to display but for now we're
just going to create two separate
components so this is going to be called
edit exercise instead of create exercise
and all this stuff is going to stay the
same something new is going to happen
though in this component did mount so
here we are in we're gonna get the users
but in it really everything's gonna be
the same here except we're not gonna set
the username because we are going to set
the username from the exercise we are
editing so we're going to have to put in
another Axios git command here so I just
pasted this in we have access that yet
we're going to HTTP local sites as it
exercises we are passing in the ID now
this or says this that props up mash up
params the ID we're getting the ID
directly from the URL here so we are now
getting the exercise that has that ID
from the backend and as a response it's
going to return that exercise and we're
going to do this that set state so we're
going to set the state of the user name
description and duration it was with the
response updated that user name that
data that description and so on here and
then here we're going to convert it into
a date we're going so we have the
correct date here and now there's just a
few other things we need to update so
instead of this actual step post and
then exercises /e add it's now going to
be exercises slash update and then we
have to pass
and the ID which is going to be this
that props
match params dot ID and then still we're
going to the second thing we're gonna
pass an exercise here and we can still
keep this the same and then we just have
a few things to change down here instead
of create a new exercise it's going to
be edit exercise log or edit with the T
and then down here it will just be edit
exercise log and we just finished that
so like I said it's very similar that
exercise McCree exercise is very similar
so now we can test this out let me go
into our exercise tracker app I'm just
going to close the console for now and
you can see we have these logged
exercises here let's just add one more
exercise so we can have another thing on
our list there so how about run Quincy's
and go for a run for only one minute so
this is going to be a very short run
because he has to take his daughter to
school so create exercise log and now we
have three exercises Oh Mary and Quincy
bike ride bike ride run we have
different durations and now the Edit
thing should work so actually the Quincy
is gonna run for a little more than one
minute we'll go to edit and then now
it's going to be 100 minutes and if I
click Edit exercise log it's now going
to show 100 minutes here and if we go to
the the dashboard here on MongoDB Atlas
we should see yet Quincy run and
duration 100 it successfully edited that
but now we're going to try delete so if
I click delete it deletes from our table
automatically and let's go see if it got
deleted from our database refresh here
and it has been deleted from the
database we just have the two items now
so now the
app is completely complete we've done
the whole thing and hopefully you've
learned a lot about how to create an app
with the myrn stack and how to use
MongoDB Atlas the code is all going to
be in the description for this so thanks
for watching my name is beau Karns and I
hope you will use your code for good